>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Susan Meinheit: Welcome
to the Library of Congress.
Thank you to the
Embassy of Mongolia
and the Mongolian
Cultural Center
for bringing this
exciting conference
to the Library again this year.
It's my pleasure to introduce
the chief of the Asian Division,
Dr. Dongfang Shao, who will
officially start the program.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Dongfang Shao:
Good afternoon.
You know, we are lucky.
You know, we only
have eight hours,
government shut down, you know.
Originally I was so concerned,
you know, we were unable
to have a meeting here.
And welcome to the
Library of Congress, yeah,
particularly the keynote speaker
to what we call the 12th
International Mongolia
Study Conference.
Yeah. I attended nine three
years ago in the Embassy, yeah.
We would like to thank Mr.
Bold Bat-Ochir, Deputy Chief
of Mission of Mongolia
to the United States,
and also the Embassy staff
and Mongolian Cultural Center
and its president,
Saruul Erdene Myagmar,
for bringing the
conference participants
to the Library of Congress.
Yeah. Asian Division has a very
large Mongolian collection,
you know, and also a very
important collection.
The resources is for
academic research.
You know, we supposed to be one
of the largest Mongolian
collection outside
of Mongolia, yeah.
And also, we have covered
179 different Asian languages
of 23 countries and areas.
Yeah, so we have the
largest collection
of Japanese collection
outside of Japan
and we have the largest
Indonesia collection,
yeah, outside Indonesia.
Yeah. So we welcome all the
visiting scholar to come
to use our collection, you
know, to conduct your research
in the Library of Congress.
Yeah. And also, I would like
to thanks the Mongolian Embassy
to send us 74 books in the
different format on behalf
of former President Elbegdorj
and his administration.
You know, these books are here
and we will have a small
ceremony to have a presentation.
Yeah.
[ Background sounds ]
[ Applause ]
Now I ask Susan Meinheit,
she is our Tibetan
and Mongolian specialist, to
reintroduce today's speaker.
[ Applause ]
>> Susan Meinheit: Okay.
Thank you.
And it's my honor to introduce
our two keynote speakers
for today's conference.
Robert McIntosh, M.S.,
is a retired U.S. National Park
Service Senior Administrator
who received the service's
Distinguished Service Award.
He now serves on the board
of the Mongol Ecology
Center in Ulaanbaatar.
Clyde Goulden, Ph.D., is
Curator Emeritus of the Academy
of Natural Sciences
at Drexel University,
and since 1996 has
been the director
of the academy's Institute
for Mongolian Biodiversity
and Ecological Studies.
He conducted his Mongolia
research under grants
from the National Science
Foundation for over 20 years.
It is my honor to present them
for an interesting presentation
on the critical importance of
science and the rule of law
in protecting the integrity
of Mongolia's Lake
Hovsgol National Park.
Gentlemen.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert McIntosh: Thank you.
Can you hear in the back?
Sound good?
Thank you.
It's Dr. Goulden and my
pleasure to have the honor
to be the keynote
at this conference.
We submitted our abstract
and then got shocked
by asking to do the keynote.
So we're a little above our pay
grade, but thank you anyways.
We obviously want to talk about
the integration of science
and public administration,
science-based decision making
in national parks in Mongolia,
and for that matter the need
that exists for that
throughout the world.
So our talk today is
focused on Lake Hovsgol,
but in your own experiences
with different parks
in different parts of
Mongolia and different parts
of the world, the
same lessons are true.
I want to start first by
just giving us a geographical
reference as to where
we are in the world.
Lake Hovsgol National Park is
the headwaters of the Selenge,
one of the many headwaters
of the Selenge
in north central Mongolia down
to Lake Baikal, and it flows
into the Yenisei
River, which is one
of the great Arctic
rivers in Siberia.
Equally important, just to
the west is the Darkhad Valley
and the Shishged River,
which also flows north
into the Yenisei and
on to the Arctic.
Lake Hovsgol National Park
and the Lake Baikal region
is the southern extent
of the permanent permafrost,
which is very important
in the issues of climate
change as we move forward.
And you can see from the
different colorations
in this slide, the red arrow
pointing to Lake Hovsgol,
that to the north is
the Siberian taiga,
and to the south is the steppe,
the Central Asian steppe.
So it's the blending
or the transition
from one major ecosystem
to another.
In local cultural
traditions, particularly
in the Lake Hovsgol area,
it is that Lake Hovsgol
itself is the Mother Sea.
Munkh Saridag Mountain to the
north along the Russian border,
looking over the frozen lake
and the Village of Hankh,
is the Father and all life
emanated from the Father
and the Great Mother Sea.
So now the rangers of Lake
Hovsgol wanted to kind
of take you on a quick
tour of the park.
This is the entrance sign,
the new entrance sign,
which was donated in 2015
by Yosemite National Park
in the United States at the
time we signed a sister park
agreement between Lake
Hovsgol and Yosemite.
You can see here in the
geographic reference
of the country, Lake Hovsgol
is that north central,
and the colors just to the left
or the west, are the three parks
that surround the
Darkhad Valley.
The park itself is
1.2 million hectares.
That's about Yellowstone
and a half again.
Various transitions
of ecosystems.
Seventy percent of
the fresh water
in Mongolia sits in that lake.
It's 267 meters deep.
Sixty-eight mammal species
are known in the park
and ten fish, one endemic.
The Hovsgol Grayling only
lives in Lake Hovsgol.
Local families and visitation,
which you will see shortly,
is skyrocketing, and we'll
discuss the impacts of that.
In 2013 the Mongol Ecology
Center worked with the park
and developed a vision statement
for the management of the park,
speaking to the diverse
cultural and natural resources
that express the
values of the Mother Sea
and the Father Mountain,
nomadic traditions and folklore,
together for the
preservation, fully integrated
with sustainable
economic development.
This is the game changer.
In the Soviet period
industrial export/import
from the Soviet Union
for 1990 to 2010 or so,
things were very quiet,
depressed economically
in Hatgal, and then in 2014
the paved road from Ulaanbaatar
to Hatgal was completed and
this is what has happened
to the visitation.
You can see early in the
2000s very little visitation.
Once the road was completed,
2017 almost 100,000
people visited the park,
and a spike in international
tourism as well.
The border between Russia and
Mongolia is now open to Russians
and Mongolians, and
there's been a huge spike
in the Russian traffic
from Irkutsk to other parts
of the Lake Baikal region coming
down to visit Lake Hovsgol.
The basis of any national
park in any country is law.
Lake Hovsgol National Park
was established in 1992.
Think about the timing there
in terms of the independence,
the constitution, the
creation of the parliament
and a very quick decision
to preserve the area
around Lake Hovsgol.
It wasn't until 1994, still
very quickly in the growth
of a new nation, that the law
on the protected
areas was established.
For national parks it
set up special zones,
sort of like our wilderness
areas, it set up travel
and tourism zones, where
temporary structures
and travel was restricted
but permissible,
and the limited use
zones, where travel,
permanent tourism facilities and
local families are authorized
to live or allowed to live.
So moving in to park
management issues, park zoning.
This map was done in 2014.
The pink area, it
is the special zone,
the sort of wilderness zone.
The tourism is the
blue, very limited areas
that are called tourism,
and then very large areas
for limited use zone.
Limited use provides
no protection
for fish spawning areas, small
natural areas, prime grasslands
and the 574 local families
that live some or all
of the year inside the park,
and you can see that number
of livestock that they husband
within the park resources.
In 1996 the parliament
of Mongolia established
the international long-term
ecological research site
to join a group of sites
across the world important
in understanding the bio
and general science
information about global issues,
and this was established
in 1996.
Research started then
and has been ongoing
in this area ever since.
Unfortunately, however,
in the Anjigas Valley,
which you can see on the map,
in 2013 unlawful construction
of a tourist facility.
In 2014 limited use zone
extended 36 miles south
from that line that
goes across the map.
And then the permit for that
construction, 18 months later,
was approved in December
of 2014.
No laws were being followed,
no standards were being
followed in that example.
And that, unfortunately,
is not the only example.
Mongolian standards
for tourism developed
in protected areas
were developed in 2013,
or a new set was established in
2013; 200 meters from the water,
setback from the water, one
kilometer between facilities,
no open toilets and livestock
and tourism facilities
must be separated
by a minimum of 500 meters.
This is the classic example
of a local family trying
to diversify economically,
and it's a challenge
obviously relative
to their standards
and what they can do.
Here's a livestock
pen, an open toilet
and a tourist facility
all within a stone's throw
of each other, which
creates public health issues,
as you can well imagine.
In 2014 we did a
survey of the ger camps
to identify the location
of all the camps
on the southwest shore.
2016 we came back
and did it again.
The red are the new camps in
a two-year period of time.
When you zoom down on this,
you can see that the
average separation
between camps is .27 meters.
The standard is one kilometer.
So again, the standard is not
being followed and the intensity
of development is
critically impacting
or has the long-term potential
to critically impact the
quality of water in the lake.
Visitor experience.
I pulled this off the
Facebook page for Hatgal.
A local Mongolian wrote
that the place was overrun,
it was dusty, it was smoky.
People can vacation, but do
they have to drink so much.
They should drive slower, they
should take their trash out,
stop driving on the grass.
Local people.
This is what they face
on a day-to-day basis.
Litter, wild camping with
no toilets, wild camping,
wild trash, no toilets,
right on the lake shore.
Waste management also creates
plastic pollution, bottles,
bags just dumped into various
depressions in the landscape
and over time, from sun and
wind, they degenerate and end
up in the lake, creating hazards
for the fish, creating hazards
in any water that's consumed
through the bioaccumulation
of plastic in the systems.
The Mongol Ecology Center Junior
Ranger Program did water quality
sampling this last
summer, five test sites.
Five sites found the water to
be clear, found the water to be
at the appropriate pH, found the
water to be low in nutrients,
but found the water to
contain fecal coliform.
The issue is just at the
edge of being serious,
but it's certainly an alarm
bell that needs to be watched.
Oil and gas pollution from
water craft, old boats,
two-cycle engines and public
safety is a serious concern
as far as dealing with folks
using boats on the water.
There are more than
70 private operators,
unregulated private operators
with tour boat type
activities on Lake Hovsgol.
Park roads, the road
on the left is the road
from Hatgal to Hankh.
The road on the right
is an improved road
on the southwest
shore of the lake.
Unintended consequences of
this type of construction,
they put the road between
the ger camps and the lake.
Now everybody complains
of the noise, the dust,
the speed of the vehicles,
and the folks from UB
and the Toyota Motor
Club have found the lake
and this was scary
to watch these six
or seven vehicles come
speeding down that road
without regard to anybody.
New roads are in the profile
of what's going to happen
in northern Hovsgol aimag.
This map on the left shows an
analysis of the various routes
to get from Muron over
to the Darkhad Valley.
The one that is seemingly
locally most favorite is
through the Jiggly Pass,
but that is the one
of highest concern.
The one down below,
with the Y, the yes,
is the one that's
being, at least as far
as this study was concerned,
being recommended
for consideration.
The west side road, 180
kilometers on the --
excuse me -- the east side
road on the right side
of the map presents similar
problems in terms of how
to develop what will
become an interstate,
international highway,
not for park use --
or one purpose will be park use,
but the road will be consumed
by commercial traffic
bringing materials north
and south from Russia.
This is what can happen if the
road's not designed properly
and if speeds are not
controlled and the type
of uses are not regulated
as well.
Managing for new uses, explosion
in tour boats on the lake,
and within the last two or
three years the appearance
of commercially rented off-road
vehicles for group tours
or for individuals,
as well as dirt bikes
to take off into
the countryside.
The way forward.
Adhere to the laws
and standards.
Adhere to the IUCN,
International Union
for the Conservation of Nature,
under UNESCO protected area
guidelines for best practices,
science-based decision
making, planning with teams
of interdisciplinary experts,
involving the community
and other stakeholders,
and most importantly,
transparent administrative
practices.
We'll now ask Dr. Goulden to
review some critical points
in the water chemistry,
the science of water,
as far as Lake Hovsgol
is concerned.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Clyde Goulden:
Thank you, Bob.
Actually, every time I
hear Bob talk about this,
there's something new
that's gone wrong.
That's very tragic.
But everything's going
beautifully here.
Thank you very much
for having us.
I want to start off just
showing you a picture
from our training program that
we had between 2002 and 2006.
We brought in, with
support from the World Bank
and the Global Environment
Facility,
18 young Mongolian researchers,
many of whom had
Master's degrees,
all of whom were supposed to
speak English so we didn't have
to worry about English
at the beginning.
They lied a little bit, but
they knew enough English
to convince me that
we'd get along okay.
On the other hand,
some of the individuals
in this photograph are
Peace Corps volunteers.
We were able to have Peace
Corps volunteers to come
up during the summer months,
on their holidays, by the way,
and teach English to
all of our researchers.
Now, let me just say
at the beginning we
started with about 18.
Two or three dropped out.
We added two or three more.
Most importantly in all of this
is that all those individuals
who completed the program, the
five-year program, and we had,
by the way, a number of
international scientists come
in for training in a
number of different areas,
all of those individuals who
finished the program ended
up going abroad for
graduate study, and of that,
12 of the individuals
returned to Mongolia
with a doctor's degree.
The rest all returned,
all of the scientists,
young scientists returned.
And as many of you know
who've worked in Mongolia,
usually when someone
leaves, they don't come back
if they can avoid it, and
that's not to criticize them,
one understands that, but
all of these individuals --
in fact, you may even
recognize some of those
from your own visitations.
There are more than obviously
18 individuals in there.
There are a number of faculty
from the National University,
from the Mongolian
Academy of Sciences,
and international scientists
that, again, we were able
to bring in for training
and specialty purposes.
So just a little
background very quickly.
And the role that I'm trying to
play here is to give you a bit
of the science, our scientific
understanding of Lake Hovsgol
and why it is so sensitive
to the kinds of problems
that Bob has just discussed.
It is a tectonic basin,
similar to Baikal.
Baikal, of course, is
about 22 million years old.
Hovsgol itself is only
about 5 million years old
and was formed during one
of the last tectonic phases
that extended the size of Lake
Baikal, but added Lake Hovsgol,
but it's separate, of course,
though they are connected
by the Selenge River,
as Bob said.
The lake is reasonably large.
Its surface area is about
the size of Lake Erie.
Though Lake Erie is around
55 meters deep, Lake Hovsgol
and these tectonic
basins are much deeper.
This is 262 meters deep, and
because of that large volume
of water, it's the 16th
largest lake in the world.
Baikal, of course,
is the largest lake.
The watershed has
been a summer home
for nomadic herders
for centuries.
I mean, you probably can go
back at least 2,000 years,
if not longer in time, where
herders have been coming
into the valley there,
or to valleys, actually.
And, of course, one of
the most important things,
and most of you familiar
with Mongolia know
that often they have
very serious droughts.
So where do you go to get
water during a drought;
you try to go to a river.
You look at the rivers and
they're totally overgrazed,
in terms of the watershed of
the river during a drought.
Hovsgol itself can
become overgrazed, too,
but it becomes a really
important place for the herders
to be able to take their
animals to get water
and generally get good pasture.
The herders are coming,
in this case,
from their winter grazing area,
which is up in the mountains,
and they come down into the
valleys during the summer,
and then again in the autumn
will start heading back
up to the top of the
mountains, and that is simply
because the valleys during the
winter are very, very cold.
So actually, you can feel
it as you walk up yourself.
You're four to five
degrees warmer as you go
up towards the top
of the mountain.
And you can see also in
that picture, by the way,
they're carrying their ger,
all of their possessions,
on the back of yaks here,
and then you can see
in the background up above the
sheep, goats, cashmere goats
and other animals
coming down the valley.
Most herders will
have at least four,
possibly five different
species of animals
that they have in their herds.
And in general, what you'll
see is that the goats,
the cashmere goats and the
sheep, are grazing up on slopes.
Horses and yaks are down
below, down near the river.
So they're actually
separated ecologically.
So even though you have a
number of fairly large herds,
they really are sort
of exploiting as much
of the slope environment
as they can.
The problems that Bob
has alluded to in terms
of construction are
really mirrored, of course,
in the ecology, the ecological
changes that are occurring now.
And what we're seeing
now is that more and more
of the watersheds, as
they're being developed
for these ger camps and
the shoreline of the lake,
that those areas of the
lake that are closest
to the shore are starting to
very serious blooms of algae.
This is the kind of problem
that most people don't think
of as a serious problem at
first, but as it expands
and those areas become
more and more polluted,
which is really what this is
all about, people become less
and less interested
in going there.
You don't want to have to
go to a lake and get out
and take a shower afterwards
so you can clean all the scum,
the algae scum off of you,
and yet that's starting
to occur more and more.
Another aspect of that, in
terms of that's a problem
of nutrient loading,
a lot of it from trash
and any erosion coming
off of the landscape,
and I'll explain what that
problem is in a minute,
but the other part is that
with rapid warming due
to climate change, the whole
area has already warmed,
is warming two to three times
faster than we are warming
with climate change,
and we talk mostly here
about a one degree warming
over the last 40 or 50 years.
In Mongolia and in parts -- much
of Siberia you're really talking
about at least a
three degree warming,
and a lot of that is simply
because the snow is melting
very rapidly, so that rather
than sunlight being
reflected back by the snow,
so the heatiness [phonetic]
is sort of reflected back.
In fact, now, that
heat that's coming
from the sun is being
absorbed by the landscape
and that's why the warming is
occurring much more rapidly.
And then finally,
as I mentioned,
the increased trash
accumulation.
So I'm going to focus on those
three points here very quickly.
Mongolia is generally
known, to begin with,
as the Blue Pearl of Mongolia.
Have any of you heard
of that before?
[ Inaudible responses ]
I just wondered, because
I started there in 1994
and that was the
first thing I learned.
Mongolians love pearls,
to begin with.
I'm pretty sure I'm
saying that correctly.
And so when they say the
Blue Pearl, you can see why.
It's really a gorgeous color.
The water is so clear, and
what happens is that with --
as you know, a rainbow has all
of the speck tore of colors,
colored light in it, but
as light goes down through,
that sunlight goes
down through the water,
different wavelengths, different
colors are being absorbed
and removed.
And the one wavelength of light
that goes the deepest
is blue light and then
that is reflected back
to the sky and the lakes,
in other words, as the ocean,
is so clear that the light
that comes back to
you when you look
down on the lake
is that blue light.
Everything else has
been filtered out.
The reason I mention
this, of course,
is this is what we want it to
look like, this is what you want
to see when you get there,
but the question is
are you always going
to be able to see it.
The concept of pollution that
we refer to in water and lakes
in particular, such as the Great
Lakes, we don't really talk
about pollution, but we could,
but there is a term
eutrophication that I think many
of you perhaps have
heard of before.
Eutrophication is a phenomenon
where a water body is shifting
from a low productive,
low nutrient system,
with very clear, clean water,
to a more polluted water,
where nutrients are coming
in stimulating algae growth.
That algae growth, in turn,
builds up a large plant biomass
in the water so it
clouds the water,
and then when that bloom dies
out, it falls to the bottom
into the sediments
of the lake and then
that begins to decompose.
Especially in a lake like
Hovsgol, where you have a lot
of oxygen already present
in that bottom water,
that plant material, dead
plant material is decomposing,
decomposing and decomposing
and taking up oxygen,
drinking oxygen continuously.
And so it's grabbing the
oxygen out of the water
and slowly these kinds of lakes
that are undergoing
eutrophication,
becoming more productive,
what happens is
that the mud itself
loses its oxygen.
The water above it loses oxygen.
And when that happens,
the nutrients
that have been suspended
in the water column,
and particularly a nutrient
like phosphorus, that has gone
down to the bottom,
remained in the sediment
under these high oxygen
conditions, when it loses
that oxygen, that phosphorus
especially, some nitrogen,
but particularly
phosphorous, now can emerge
from the sediments and it
comes back up into the water
and fertilizes the
growth of algae.
So that what basically
is happening is
that as you're undergoing
this gradual increase
in productivity, increase
of growth of plant material
in the water column, it is
then regenerating itself,
recovering those
nutrients, bringing it back
up into the water and so
you not only have the influx
of nutrients from the watershed,
but you now have an influx,
as it were, from the sediment.
So it's a reinforcement effect
that builds up very quickly,
and this really increases.
The lakes that you've seen
maybe here in Virginia or in --
no, we're not in
Virginia, sorry --
in Pennsylvania where
I come from, in Kansas,
in Indiana where I've
studied lakes before,
you start to get ponds,
especially Michigan,
or Lake Erie, many
of you know --
remember the description
of Lake Erie?
Lake Erie is dead.
What did they mean by that?
What they actually meant,
obviously the water was there,
the basin was there,
it's all there,
but you don't find very much
life in many areas of the lake,
and it's that living material,
of course, that has died,
has released its nutrients.
They've gone back up in that
reinforcing kind of change
that is going on, but it chokes
out the oxygen so that many
of the organisms present,
fishes, et cetera, are dying.
It's a very serious problem, and
that's why Lake Erie was said
to be dead, though it's not,
and hopefully it's starting
to return, in fact, but
it's reversing itself again.
So what are the kinds of
problems that are causing this.
Water quality studies of the
tributary streams that we did
in 1999 to 2000 found that
livestock grazing itself,
this is before tourism
really built up,
livestock grazing itself
is fertilizing algae
and plant growth, as just
described, mostly in the bays
or in the near shore areas.
Those are the areas that
are being hit first.
And, of course, those are
the areas that tourists want
to spend their time in.
The increased photosynthesis
then increases --
and this is an interesting
point, but it can end
up increasing the alkalinity
of the water and when
that alkalinity -- in one
bay that we measured --
if you know the pH scale,
neutral is around seven
and you go up to
ten, you're really
in a very alkaline situation,
or you go down to four or five,
you're in a very acid system.
We found one area, one bay with
fish kills with a pH of 9.8.
I won't go into the reason
for that, but if anyone wants
to know, we can discuss it.
One of the really key points to
understand about Lake Hovsgol is
that most of the geology in
that area consists of dolomite,
sort of a limestone, a
slight variation on the theme
of limestone, but this dolomite
is very rich in phosphorus.
And again, phosphorus
is a major nutrient,
if not the major nutrient
limiting this plant growth
in lakes.
So the whole effect of
the watershed coming in,
the nutrients from the
watershed coming in,
going into the sediment,
being regenerated back
up into the water, is being
reinforced overall by half
of the watershed of Lake
Hovsgol, consisting of dolomite
that is loaded with phosphorus.
Anything that is done
in the lake almost
without care is going to end up
being a problem in Lake Hovsgol.
The issue on this, of
course, I said unregulated
as a point there, the
lake is very sensitive.
If it is regulated with
the kinds of things
that Bob was talking
about, you don't have to end
up with this kind of a problem.
If those ger camps keep
being built the way
that they were described,
you can imagine what's
going to happen.
It's going to be very
serious in the future.
Right now I happen to be
involved with a project
from the Asian Development Bank,
where the bank is very
appropriately investing a great
deal of money trying
to help the people
of Lake Hovsgol develop
a tourism industry
and the issue is, of course,
which direction is
it going to take.
Is it going to take a
regulated direction,
where everyone follows the best
guidelines to protect the lake,
or is it going to
go in a direction
where people ignore
those problems,
as they are doing right now,
and causing the lake to go
in a direction of
very serious problems.
As some of you know, Baikal is
becoming more and more polluted
in many areas and what you
see in the watershed now,
more and more, are these
kinds of algae growths,
and that's the kind of
thing, most certainly,
not only on the bottom --
these are benthic algae growing
on the bottom, but
also up in the water,
so the water turns green.
Then you have the whole
aspect of climate change.
So we have this problem
with nutrients in the lake.
We also have a problem with
climate change, and I think many
of you have been
introduced to that enough
so that you'll appreciate
what I'm referring to here.
We've been doing interviews
with nomadic herders and trying
to get their perceptions,
understand their perceptions
of how climate change is
affecting their lives.
And these are some of the
questions and the responses,
just to give you an idea
of how the herders --
and let me say one thing.
Some people, when you're a
[inaudible], seem to suggest,
oh, those herders, they don't
know what they're doing,
you know, they're just going
around out there somewhere,
not really protecting
their environment.
In fact, in my mind
it's quite the opposite.
They're very concerned
and they're extremely
good observers.
So what is the biggest
environmental impact
on the lives of the herders,
as they responded to us.
The first issue is
changing weather.
It's not saying weather,
which we all complain
about the weather.
They're complaining about
the weather changing.
Actually, over the last few days
maybe we've had a lot change,
but.
Overgrazing is much less a
serious problem for herders
as is the changing weather.
And then you ask them
are the seasons changing,
trying to break down that
whole idea and other aspects
of what they mean
by changing weather.
The timing of the
seasons has changed,
and this is really important.
As you know, nomadic
herders that are moving
to the mountaintops during
the winter, they start moving
in autumn, they have to
know when to start moving,
and traditionally they have
usually started sometime
in late August, early September.
Remember, that's
pretty far north.
So they have a timing for when
they move up into the mountains
to get away from the cold
valleys, and they have a timing
for when they move back down
to the valleys in the spring
because they have to always
worry about their water sources.
So the timing of the
seasons has changed
and it is creating substantial
problems for the herders.
The winters are milder,
as you would expect.
Summers are cooler, but are
mixed with very warm days and,
in fact, they now say that
they are having heatwaves,
in the same way that
we have heatwaves,
and that the heatwaves
are burning the grass.
And finally, and the thing
that I want to emphasize here
for the next couple of slides,
is they say the rains have
changed, and they will describe
to you that rains used to be a
light silky rain that might last
for two or three days.
Now, it's coming in gushes.
And you've seen that, I'm
sure, yourself around here,
so I'm not telling you anything
that you haven't
witnessed as a change.
And I think if you
consider all the things
that have been occurring with
some of these really heavy rains
where it washes cars off
of Long Island Expressway,
and there was one big storm
that came out of Chicago
and came right down to
Washington area here,
flooded tremendously, these are
not historically common events.
They may have occasionally
occurred in the past,
but they are increasing
in frequency.
For Mongolia, what
you're beginning
to see now are these
really heavy,
hard rains that are coming
in and they look like this,
if you can sort of -- I hope
you can see, right in the center
above those houses, there's a
very heavy rainstorm occurring.
That happens to be south
of us and we just happened
to be heading that way.
This kind of a rain
is called a --
by the Mongols is
called an aadar rain.
Many of you fluent in
Mongolia will know that term.
This is the kind of rain you
don't want to stand outside
and feel this warm rain
coming down on you.
That would have been the kind
of rain they would
expect in the past.
Now what they're finding
are cold rains coming down,
large drops that are coming down
very rapidly on top of them,
and they become very, very
concerned about their children
when there are children
are outside.
Some of these rains are so hard
that they can kill animals,
and I'm not exaggerating that.
I hope you appreciate.
Just to show you now,
this happens to be --
one of the things that the
herders say was, again,
we used to have these two- or
three-day rains, half day maybe,
a couple of days, light rains.
Now we're having
really intense rains.
Overall there's not a big
increase in the amount
of rainfall annually, it's
just coming delivered now,
instead of a slow, gradual rain,
it's coming down in torrents.
It's coming down
very hard, as I said.
And what you see on this
graph is that everything
above that horizontal line,
where on the top there
it says aadar rain,
every rain above that
line is an aadar rain,
and this is a very,
very heavy rain.
This is from 2008,
2009, 2010, 2011, 2012.
Every year.
The number on top of the
line represents the length
of that rain.
So, for example, look at 2010.
You have rains that are
aadar rains, very hard rains
that are lasting 15, 30,
15 minutes, ten minutes,
five minutes, with three
millimeters every five
minutes occurring.
Now, that may not
sound like very much,
but that's a lot of
rain coming down.
And this is what the herders say
as a result of our interviews
and discussing it with them.
The herders claim the aadar
rains were very damaging
to their pastures, animals
and to their families
while watching the herds.
They're very concerned
about their children,
especially when they're out
because often the child will go
out without a shirt on and then
you have one of these cold,
drenching rains come
down and, of course,
hypothermia then becomes
a very serious problem.
It's very common now.
The rain eroded the road,
very intense, dangerous.
The ger was flooded,
mattresses were floating,
pasture covered with
running water.
That's not typical,
certainly not historically.
In previous year -- these
are different herders
that are telling us this.
In previous year, 2011,
had extremely intense,
hard rain, killed many animals.
Now, how many animals do
we kill when we have one
of our rains right now?
One of those really
heavy rains killed a lot
of cars, I know that.
Some people were
harmed, in fact, but.
We had extremely hard,
windy rain that knocked
down many trees.
Our fodder, their food that
they collect for the winter
for their animals, our fodder
was blown up into the air.
We lost half of the fodder.
Our ger was damaged and
knocked down in 2010.
And these gers are
pretty well fixed,
and yet the aadar rain can knock
them down and blow them around.
Last year at the end of July
I experienced aadar boroo.
That's rain, aadar rain.
It was dangerously intense.
And in most cases these
rains are ending up in floods
when they get at Hovsgol,
near the lake itself.
If you could, on the
upper left there,
if you could just
walk straight out,
you would actually
see the lake there.
It's just beyond it.
But what happens is when the
stream following an aadar rain
is coming down towards the
lake, it sort of backs up.
The lake is acting
as a dam for it,
so it backs up in the
whole pasture area.
This is a stream that originally
is about 25 feet across,
nothing more than that.
And you can see two
of our researchers,
they're actually looking for
insects, not for fish there.
So you get a perspective
on what that river is like.
Now, look at above that
and over to the right,
if you look just beyond --
I don't know if you can --
I don't know if I can point out.
If you look up in the
upper right corner there,
you see dots there.
There are four yaks and
a couple of horses there
that got isolated out on a
little knob, not recognizing --
I mean, they're sitting there
grazing and not recognizing
that the whole valley
was flooding.
But I leave that in for scale
as you can compare the two
researchers versus the yaks
and the horses for scale.
So aadar rains now, all of the
herders say, and I haven't put
in the analysis for that,
but all of the herders are
saying the aadar rains are much
more common now.
We used to have these
light rains,
now we're having these
very intense rains.
It's not always the
only rain that occurs,
but nevertheless, it is there.
This is a rainfall right
here that is about two inches
over a two-day period.
We've had some rains more
than that, I'm afraid.
So my concern, Bob's
concern for Lake Hovsgol,
and I think the concern
of many people,
is rather substantial
and with good reason.
Our research on Lake
Hovsgol suggests
that strict protection
guidelines need to be followed
as the bay and shoreline
areas, the lakes,
watershed are developed
for tourism
and as the climate
continues to change.
This is critical in order
to avoid serious problems
in the future that would
very likely include blooms
of nuisance aquatic plant
growths, fish kills,
more flooding, and would
quickly discourage tourists
from visiting the park and
all of the efforts then
to build tourism would
have come to nothing.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Susan Meinheit: Do you
wish to take questions?
>> Robert McIntosh: Yeah.
>> Susan Meinheit: We have
plenty of time for questions.
I just wanted to say
that because the Library
of Congress is preparing
a webcast of this program,
any questions that you ask, you
would be giving your permission
to be filmed and appear in a
later webcast of the program.
So with that caveat,
please ask questions.
>> Clyde Goulden: How many of
you have been to Lake Hovsgol?
Wow. That's a good --
that's pretty good.
Have you seen changes in fishing
and in some cases plants growing
where they hadn't been
growing before in the water?
It's a slow process,
a really slow process.
It's only really
building up now.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible comments ]
>> Robert McIntosh: The story
you tell was a story you could
tell of the United
States 50, 75 years ago.
>> Yeah.
>> Robert McIntosh:
And the people
of the United States
finally became, themselves,
so upset that there
were national campaigns,
just signs on TV and all those
different types of media,
to tell people to care for the
landscape and don't litter.
So that changed the mentality,
coupled with more intense
litter patrolling, particularly
in the parks, because I think if
people see litter, they litter.
>> Right.
>> Robert McIntosh: If
they don't see litter,
they think twice about
throwing the plastic bag
or the cigarettes, or
whatever, out the car window
or leaving them behind.
So I think it's both a role
of the government to respond
to that, but most importantly
you have to change the mindset
of the population,
and the best way to do
that is national campaigns
to just make people aware
of what they're doing
to themselves.
[ Inaudible comments ]
>> Robert McIntosh: Yeah,
that's a problem not
unique to Mongolia.
But again, I think even with
plastic in retail and so on,
if people are educated, they
will strive to take care of it
as opposed to just littering.
And there are campaigns in
Europe and campaigns starting
in the United States to just
try to eliminate as much plastic
from the retail stream as
possible, and that's a long road
to follow, but hopefully it will
be successful in those places
that are trying it, and it can
be tried in Mongolia as well.
>> Clyde Goulden: Now,
it may sound, by the way,
that we're only worried
about Lake Hovsgol,
but I think Bob has said enough,
and I would certainly
reinforce the whole issue,
that what is happening there is
happening in many of the parks.
One of the things that really
attracted me to Mongolia
to begin with is that they
have established a plan
for protecting 15 percent,
if not more, in fact,
almost 25 percent at one time,
of their area in national parks.
That goal at least has reached
the 15 percent part now,
and in each one of these parks,
some of them much more protected
than others because they haven't
attracted people as much there,
but as they do, there is an
ethic that has to be recognized
and established for what
happens when you go into a park.
Our National Park Service has
done a great deal and continues
to do a great deal, and in
Mongolia they will, I know,
catch on and begin
to do that, too.
>> Robert McIntosh: I'll give
you a quick little case study.
Three years ago we started a
Junior Ranger Program in Hatgal
and this year we'll have it --
it's already started in Hankh
at the northern end of the lake.
After the first summer camp
a couple of the kids went
to the local store in the
main strip of Hatgal and stood
at the door and when people
left, they challenged them
as to what they were going
to do with that plastic bag
or what they were going to do
with that empty Coke bottle,
and made them promise,
basically,
that they would not just
throw it into the countryside.
So here we've got a sixth-,
seventh-grader who's already
understanding what the issues
are and starting to try to
make a change, and the more
that we can do that type of
thing and touch one person
at a time, the problem
goes away.
Yes.
>> I agree with you about
the role of our children
in all this [inaudible].
It obviously worked
in the United States
and we're seeing it
work in Mongolia.
I want to ask about the
possible role of the people
who have the guest gers
around the side of the lake
and whether you see --
because we saw the same thing
in a national park in
western Mongolia, the Altai,
and I keep wondering whether
the role of the guides
and the guests and their owners,
is it their place to report it.
>> Robert McIntosh:
Yeah, obviously.
Obviously.
And they all have
different motivations
and they all have
different sensitivities.
Some, I think, are very strong
in terms of eliminating plastic
in the waste stream and making
sure that their guests pick
up trash, and if they don't,
they pick up the trash.
>> Well, the toilets also, yeah.
>> Robert McIntosh: And
the toilets also, yeah.
I mean, we didn't get into
that topic, but that is one
of the biggest topics
at the lake
and in other high
tourist areas in Mongolia.
The standard says
no open toilets,
no outhouses, so to speak.
Making that transition
is expensive and because
of the climate, the
technology is very challenging.
So the ADB project that Clyde
mentioned is addressing that.
How successful that first phase
of that is going to be is still,
I think, the jury is out.
But the people around Lake
Hovsgol who live there,
the ADB recognizes that.
We certainly recognized
that in our study in 2013,
that some of the biggest
challenges the park was going
to face were transportation
issues
and waste management issues.
In the back.
>> My question is besides
regulation, how [inaudible].
>> Robert McIntosh: I
think we're starting
to see that evolve.
There are nuggets of groups
that tourist providers
in Hatgal have created an
association to address some
of these issues, so I think
slowly but surely you'll see --
and in Hankh also,
slowly but surely see some
of these issues being addressed
by local citizens and businesses
to sustain the economic
advantage that they have,
because as Clyde pointed out
in a couple of his slides,
if it's a dump, people aren't
going to want to go there.
Yes.
[ Inaudible comments ]
Have you got two or three hours?
We can get into this.
But in summary, I think
one of the problems
in the tourist facility
development is
that there are multiple layers
of approval, and depending
on what way you read
this law versus that law,
it's somewhat confusing as
to who has the authority.
But generally speaking,
the park,
the soon [phonetic]
governor, the aimag governor
and the minister
approve a permit.
But there's also sort
of a sideway exception
that the soon governor has
permission to grant permits
to local families for grazing,
and then those families set
up a couple of gers for a side
principal or secondary economy.
I'm not sure.
But because of that, and there's
no one point of authority,
people are finding ways to drive
over it, around it and under it
to get -- it's going to
take a strong recognition
of the problem and a new
commitment, basically,
to start to try to
sort this out.
There's a new director
at Lake Hovsgol.
He's been there almost
two years now.
He's serious about addressing
this issue, but there are a lot
of factors that are forcing
him to compromise and try
to make things happen
in the right way,
but at least it's starting.
And I can tell you in the
history of the United States,
of the national parks
in the United States,
a hundred years ago we had
very similar type problems.
So it's not like this
can't be corrected.
[ Inaudible comment ]
On the which?
I'm sure it exists.
We don't have it.
But I do know that there are
more incidences in recent times
than there were historically,
and you can see
from the seven year or so
commercial boat operators
that are taking people
out on the lakes.
And I've heard stories that, you
know, life jackets are required,
but they're homemade life
jackets that don't really work.
And, you know, if you fall
in a lake in Virginia,
the water's relatively
warm and you can survive.
You fall into Lake Hovsgol,
the water temperature,
even on the warmest day of
the year, is not warm enough
to allow you to survive.
And if you're way out in
the middle of the lake
and help can't get
to you quickly,
that's not going
to be a good story.
Thank you all very much.
>> Clyde Goulden:
Yeah, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Susan Meinheit: My
name is Susan Meinheit
and I'm the Tibetan and
Mongolian specialist
in the Asian Division of
the Library of Congress.
[ Background conversations ]
I'm going to do a
brief presentation
on the Mongolian collection
and then I will lead you
over to the display
I've prepared.
So, please, take your seats.
Bring your coffee.
[ Background conversations ]
The Asian Division was
founded in 1928 and it's one
of the four area
studies divisions
of the Library of Congress.
We are a custodial division
for Asian language materials,
with over four million
volumes of monographs
in over 130 Asian languages.
The Mongolian collection
currently consists
of about 11,000 monographs,
170 serial titles,
almost 4,000 microfiche,
175 reels of microfilm,
and about 600 volumes
of rare books.
The first Mongolian books came
to the Library of Congress
between 1893 and 1901 as gifts
from the American diplomat
William Woodville Rockhill,
and the rare collection
now has about 600 volumes,
including complete
reprint editions
of the Mongolian
Kanjur and Tanjur.
This is the first Mongolian
book to come to the Library
of Congress, a gift from
William Rockhill in 1893.
It's a very beautiful
Mongolian edition of the Sutra
of the Great Liberation,
Tharpa Chenpo in Tibetan.
So in 1992 the Library began
a current acquisitions program
for Mongolian through the
New Delhi field office,
which continues today.
We have a vendor in Ulaanbaatar
who ships books via the
U.S. Embassy every month
to the Library.
We also acquire Mongolian
language material published
worldwide, including
China, Taiwan, Russia.
And we have a very small
collection of publications
in Kalmyk, Buryat, and
other related languages.
So I've named today's display
Sutras and Silver Lakes,
Books and Scenes of Mongolia, in
honor of this conference topic.
The display focuses primarily
on Hovsgol Lake and Aimag.
The two glass cases include
several small sutras, sudars,
about respecting nature,
surrounded by images of lakes
and mountains, the landscapes
to which they belong.
This part of the display will be
on view until the end of March
in case you don't have
time to look at it today.
Included in the display
is a remote sensing map
of Hovsgol National Park
which was scanned to us
from originals found
in the Library's
Geography and Map Division.
Two other maps and the
[inaudible] of this one are also
on the open display cases.
And I thank our colleagues from
Geography and Map Division,
if they're here, for kindly
loaning these items for today.
Geography and Map Division
has a very large collection
of Mongolian maps, which can
be searched online using search
terms, Hovsgol maps or just
Mongolia maps, and you'll get
about 150 different items.
Next to the map there is a
1989 Russian atlas of the lake,
atlas of Hovsgol Lake, also
from Geography and Map Division.
It features very colorful graphs
and charts documenting studies
of the lake made
between 1971 and 1986.
The cases also feature
several small texts
from our Mongolian
rare book collection.
These reflect Mongolians'
traditional deep respect
for the environment.
Included is an interesting
19th century sudar
of Tsorj Lama Avgaandorj,
emphasizing the importance
of respecting the spirit of
nature by praying to the sky,
earth, land and country.
Other small sutras offer praise
to mountains, earth and sky.
The countertop dismay features
a wide selection of books
on Hovsgol, its history,
culture, folk songs, legends,
tourism, wildlife, wild flowers
and environmental issues.
You can see the Library of
Congress catalogue search terms
which could be used for
information on these books,
and you can see we
spell in a variety
of different [inaudible]
systems in the catalogue.
And these are some of the
subject headings you can search
for further information.
These are all established
Library
of Congress subject headings,
legends, Mongolia, Hovsgol,
Aimag, Tales, Mongolia,
Darkhad, Mongolian people,
folklore, et cetera, et cetera.
And if you're interested
in more information
on our Mongolian collection,
you can start by searching here.
And these are also subject
headings that I used
in preparing the display;
wildlife conservation,
biodiversity conservation
Mongolia,
ecosystem management Mongolia.
You can see we have a
very extensive collection.
Reindeer herding, et cetera.
The display also
features several books
from the Library's Law
Library on Mongolian laws
for environmental protection.
They also can be searched
by the various Library
of Congress subject
headings here.
And finally, the display
includes a few miscellaneous
books related to other
topics in the conference.
For example, the travel
book by Beatrix Bulstrode,
and books on the history
of Mongolian television,
a book on Buryat poetry, for
our visitor from Buryatia.
And all of these
books are available
in the Asian Reading Room, which
is located across the Great Hall
from here, Jefferson LJ150.
We're open Monday
through Friday, 8:30 to 5.
This is our website.
And now, if you have questions,
I'll be happy to answer them,
and then if you could
finish your refreshments
and we could go over and
take a look at the display.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.